السماء بدات تمطر مطر من صنع البشر عبر
تحفيز السحب وتلقيح الغيوم والنتيجه زخات
مطر اصطناعيه في القرن السابع عشر كانت
اول محاوله من قبل البشر لاسقاط الامطار
من السماء نابليون بونابرت اطلق قذائف نحو
السماء بهدف تفتيت السحب واسقاط المطر بعد
ذلك توالت المحاولات الاكثر تقدما في
الولايات المتحده عن طريق البالونات
الهوائيه ومره عن طريق الطائرات الورقيه
لايصال المتفجرات الى السحب لكن كل ذلك
نتج عنه عدد كبير من الحرائق في الاراضي
الامريكيه الى ان جاء عام
1946 عندما اجتاح جفاف كبير البلاد
حينئذ توصل العلماء الى تقنيه الاستنطار
عن طريق التلقيح الاصطناعي
عمليه الاستمطار الاصطناعي لا تولد امطارا
بل هي عمليه تعمل على زياده كميه ونوعيه
الامطار عن طريق استثاره وتحفيز السحب
والغيوم لاسقاط محتواها باستخدام مواد
كيميائيه تعمل على تسريع عمليه هطول
الامطار او زياده ادرار هذه السحب من
المياه
هذه المواد الكيميائيه تنثر بين او فوق
السحب الواقعه على ارتفاع يتراوح بين 2004
الاف متر وهناك تقنيتان لهذه العمليه
الاولى تتمثل بالقاء طائره لصواريخ مليئه
بكلوريد الصوديوم او يوديد الفضه هذه
الجزيئات تؤدي دور النواه العملاقه التي
تكبر شيئا فشيئا وتسمح بتكثف بخار الماء
الموجود في السحب ليصبح ماء سائلا جاهزا
للهطول في غضون 15 الى 30 دقيقه اما
التقنيه الثانيه والاقل كلفه فتتمثل في
اطلاق صواريخ صغيره من الارض تحتوي على
هذه الجزيئات فيما تعد تكلفه الاستمطار
اقل بنحو 60 ضعفا من تكلفه تحليه المياه
ويزيد نوعا ما من عشره الى ثلاثين بالمئه
تقريبا من كميه مياه الامطار
تعملنا حسابات ان
الاستمرار ارخص بكثير من عمليات تحليه
المياه ولكن طبعا الاستمرار يتطلب وجود
سحب ممطره
فيمكن هذه هي المشكله اننا مش دائما تكون
في سحب
زرع السحب وزياده هطول الامطار شائع في
كثير من الدول العربيه كالسعوديه
والامارات وتتم غالبا عبر تلقيح السحب
والغيوم من خلال الطائرات
اما في الصين التي تثير الجدل دائما
بتقنياتها المتقدمه فيتم احيانا اللجوء
الى استخدام المعدات العسكريه لا سيما تلك
المتمركزه في المناطق الجافه من اجل
الاستنطار الاصطناعي